the list of people who believe that Donald
Trump is not going to relinquish control of
the White House.
He's fully, if he loses the 2020 election
is growing and it includes at least one Republican
candidate now who happens to be running against
Donald Trump.
His name's William Weld.
He is a former governor here in Massachusetts.
He previously was running as a libertarian.
He now is a Republican and he says that Donald
Trump will not leave voluntarily if he loses
the 2020 election from real time with Bill
Maher.
Bill Maher asked if Trump loses, do you think
he'll leave?
And William Weld said, not voluntarily.
He'll have a run at saying it was a rigged
game, so I'm not leaving.
I don't think the military and indeed even
the Justice Department, the rank and file,
the investigative agencies would stand for
that in this country.
I like that William Weld added that last piece
because it's important for us on the Left
and not that William Weld is on the left,
but for anyone on the left who is even entertaining
this idea of what would Trump do, what did
he try to hold on to control if he lost the
2020 election?
We're not like the crazy right with the birther
stuff and the Obama's going to cancel the
2016 election stuff, which is why I think
it's important to point out that William Weld
is not saying Trump would succeed at staying
in the White House.
Even if you lost the 2020 election.
He might try to pull it or try to delay it,
but ultimately the centers of power in the
country wouldn't allow it.
And I also think that that's the most likely
scenario and every single time that this comes
up, I go out of my way not to be hyperbolic,
because with Obama there was so much nonsense
about Obama won't leave.
Obama will cancel the 2016 election and declare
himself indefinite president or Obama will
declare martial law as a justification for
remaining president beyond his eight years.
We want to be a sober and realistic as possible
about this with Barack Obama.
There was no indication whatsoever that Barack
Obama had those sort of anti-democratic authoritarian
tendencies with regard to the presidency and
trying to, uh, not relinquish power.
There was nothing Obama said, which suggested
that he might out of his own concoction, not
accept the results of an election.
So when the right set, Obama won't leave,
it was 110% bs.
With Trump.
It's not a 110% bs.
It's still not likely that it would happen
though.
Right? Trump has all the way back to 2016
in the debates said maybe he would accept
the election results.
Maybe he wouldn't if they showed that he lost,
depending on what he thinks about the election
results.
Trump has said president for life, like what
China made possible recently is interesting
and maybe we would try it sometime.
Trump has said years ahead of the 2020 election
two years ahead, that the only way Democrats
can defeat them in 2020 is via fraud.
That is yet another one of these sort of pretext
to the idea that he might not accept the election
results.
Trump has lied about the validity of past
elections.
Remember he claimed three to 5 million people
voted illegally in 2016 for Hillary Clinton.
And that in reality, if you account for those
three to 5 million alleged illegal votes,
he won the popular vote as well as the electorial
vote.
Trump has made clear that he has a degree
of narcissism that might make him unable emotionally
to accept defeat.
So when people talk about Trump won't leave
the White House peacefully, if you loses,
is it more likely that he would try to retain
power?
Uh, then would someone like Barack Obama?
Obviously the answer is yes.
Is it likely Trump would succeed if he tried
at not relinquishing the White House?
I don't think is very likely.
So what what we need to do is let's just work
on voting him out rather than focusing on
whether or not he would leave.
Let's work on preventing voter suppression
and manipulation tactics to actually hand
Donald Trump the victory because much more
likely than Trump loses and somehow stays
in the White House, is that the combination
of voter id laws and election machine tampering
and foreign influence and reductions and voting
hours and closures of polling places all together
push Donald Trump into victory.
That's what we need to most proactively be
working to prevent.
I agree with William Weld that if Trump tries
not to give up control of the White House,
uh, that the forces of power, I know that
the Justice Department in the tank forum,
I know all of that stuff, but I think that
that would even be too far.
I think that he would ultimately be removed.
And there's a really big problem in American
culture today, American political culture
today, that this relates to expectations.
Expectations aren't being managed properly.
So taking payment, for example, which we'll
talk about, the expectations shouldn't be,
can we remove Trump via impeachment by the
2020 election?
Because that's not happening.
The expectation should be Ken impeachment
proceedings expose the content of the molar
report enough to damage Trump to make sure
that he loses the 2020 election.
We have to manage our expectations.
And similarly, if Trump loses the 2020 election
and tries to stay in power, could he actually
do it?
I believe William Weld is right, and the answer
is no.
That he would be removed, but he might try
to argue that the election was bogus, that
it was rigged, that it was fraudulent, whatever.
Because he's done it before in an election
he won.
But who knows what he would do in an election
that he loses.
Last thing on this, the idea that, uh, the
reason Trump would be so adamant about not
losing has been floated as maybe being the
statute of limitations on obstruction.
There's this idea that Trump does not so much
that he wants to be president for another
four years, although his ego would take a
hit if you were to lose, but it's the idea
that if he is not president for another four
years, he could end up indicted for obstruction
because the statute of limitations would not
have expired.
There is a way around that which would be
if Trump loses the 2020 election three days
before the inauguration of the next president
Trump resigns.
Mike pence becomes president and issues of
preemptive pardon for Donald Trump.
It might work.
It might not.
The legal experts have sort of different views
on that, but there is a path.
Even if Trump loses in 2022 protecting himself
from indictment on obstruction after he's
gone.
Just something to keep in mind.